evil does not sleep  it waits something is coming back to the  dark ages the devil in his army  you know the world is broken this is the  only way i watched  he said the age of heroes would never  come again  don't engage alone we do this together  [Music]  i want you to listen to me perry because  i mean  this i'm putting together a team of  people with special abilities  you can be whatever you want to be i  can't sit here  and watch you run in place you have to  run faster than you've ever attempted  you're brilliant man absolute best of  the best  make your own future your own future  make your own past  all right now  you can turn your back on the world  forever  above or below thousands of years since  our people spoke the first born of  beloved queen of blood  i need warriors you can't be scared  the time has come take up your mother's  privates  this is a bad idea  fighting the devil in his army i know  you